THESE ARE VULNERABILITIES THAT
ANY ADVERSARY COULD PURSUE.
SO WE THINK THE THREAT REMAINS
HIGH.
>> Bret: A LOT OF TESTIMONY ON
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT TRYING TO
PROTECT THE BALLOT BOXES IN THE
U.S.
2018, BEYOND, FOR MUSHY
INTERFERENCE.
THEN ANOTHER BREAKING STORY LATE
THIS AFTERNOON.
ABC NEWS HAD A STORY ABOUT
ANDREW McCABE.
NEARLY A YEAR BEFORE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
FIRED SENIOR FBI OFFICIAL ANDREW
McCABE FOR WHAT SESSIONS
CALLED A LACK OF CANDOR,
McCABE OVERSIGHT FEDERAL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO
WHETHER SESSIONS LIKE CANDOR
WHEN TESTIFYING BEFORE CONGRESS
ABOUT CONTACTS WITH RUSSIAN
OPERATIVES.
THE SESSIONS WAS NOT AWARE OF
THE INVESTIGATION WHEN HE
DECIDED TO FIRE McCABE LAST
FRIDAY.
LAST YEAR, SEVERAL TOP
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKERS WERE INFORMED OF THE
PROBE DURING A CLOSED-DOOR
BRIEFING WITH DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND McCABE.
A SESSIONS' PERSONAL LAWYER SAID
THAT HE IS NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION AND THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INFORMED HIM
THAT THERE WAS NO SUCH
INVESTIGATION.
McCABE AND THE FIRING,
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, THE FBI
DIRECTOR, WAS ASKED BY NBC TODAY
ABOUT THAT FIRING OVER THE
WEEKEND.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I'M COMMITTED TO DOING THINGS
OBJECTIVELY AND INDEPENDENTLY
END BY THE BOOK.
I THINK THAT HAS TO EXTEND, NOT
JUST TO OUR INVESTIGATIONS, OUR
INTELLIGENCE ANALYSIS COME OF IT
BUT IT ALSO HAS TO EXTEND TO
PERSONNEL DECISIONS AND
DISCIPLINARY DECISIONS.
>> I WANT TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT I CAN SAY ABOUT THE PROCESS
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT MY
COMMITMENT TO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR PROCESS IS FOLLOWED, THAT IT
RELIES ON OBJECTIVE INPUT, AND
THAT MOST IMPORTANTLY, IT IS NOT
BASED ON POLITICAL OR PARTISAN
INFLUENCE IS SOMETHING I AM
UTTERLY UNYIELDING ON.
>> Bret: AGAIN, ASK THE
QUESTION, HE SAYS EVERYTHING
WENT BY THE BOOK.
THUS BRINGING OUR PANEL.
STEVE HAYES, AN EDITOR IN CHIEF
OF THE WEEKLY STANDARD.
KAREN TUMULTY, OPINION EDITOR
FOR "THE WASHINGTON POST."
AND BILL BENNETT, HOST OF "THE
BILL BENNETT PODCAST."
YOU HAVE TO PIECE THEM
ALTOGETHER, THESE STORIES.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS "ABC NEWS"
STORIES AND WILL CHRISTOPHER
WRAY JUST SAID.
>> IT'S HARD TO DIGEST BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A DENIAL BY SESSIONS'
LAWYER THAT THIS WAS ACTUALLY
GOING ON.
IT IS THE STORY TRUE OR NOT?
IF THE STORY IS TRUE, I THINK
THE LANGUAGE OF THE ABC REPORT
WAS -- HE WAS -- McCABE WAS
OVERSEEING THE INVESTIGATION.
WHO AUTHORIZED THE
INVESTIGATION?
THE STORY SUGGESTS THE
INSTIGATION CAME FROM THE HILL
TO DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
AL FRANKEN AND LAHEY.
WHO AUTHORIZED IT?
THE THING I'M INTERESTED IN AS
THIS LAST THING YOU PLAYED.
WRAY NOW INSERTS HIMSELF BETWEEN
THE OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, THE OFFICE OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OR IF YOU WILL,
ATTORNEY GENERALS SESSIONS,
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS
DECISION.
McCABE, WE NEED THIS INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT.
WE NEED IT SOON.
TO FIND OUT REALLY WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
>> Bret: IT'S COMING OUT IN
THE COMING WEEKS.
WE WERE THINKING DAYS BUT
PROBABLY WEEKS.
KAREN, THE FACT OF THE FBI
DIRECTOR, WHO WE HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM HIM ABOUT HIS DEPUTIES
FIRING, IS SAYING IT WAS BY THE
BOOK, KIND OF TAMPS DOWN A
LITTLE BIT OF THE RAPPORT UP
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S TWEETS
OVER THIS.
>> YEAH, I THINK IT DOES.
THE PRESIDENT'S TWEETS CERTAINLY
DIDN'T HELP.
HE PROCEEDED TO INFLAME THE
WHOLE SITUATION.
BUT THE WHOLE -- THE REVELATION
THAT SESSIONS HIMSELF MAY HAVE
BEEN UNDER INVESTIGATION ALSO
GOES BACK TO WHAT END
DONALD TRUMP'S MIND IS THE
ORIGINAL CENSURE, THE THING HE'S
BEEN AT HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PRESIDENCY, WHICH IS SESSIONS'
DECISION TO RECUSE HIMSELF FROM
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
THIS SUGGESTS THAT EVEN IF HE
HADN'T HAD NOT THEN, HE WOULD
HAVE HAD TO EVENTUALLY HAVE DONE
IT.
>> Bret: STEVE?
>> YOU HAVE SEEN EVEN SOME OF
THE PRESIDENT'S MOST VOCIFEROUS
CRITICS ON THE LEFT, DEMOCRATS,
SAY THAT THE McCABE FIRING MAY
WELL HAVE BEEN JUSTIFIED.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN BRIEFED ON
THE DETAILS OF THIS, IF THEY
WERE NOT JUSTIFIED, THEY WOULD
LET US KNOW RATHER LOUDLY.
I THINK THAT IS A FACTOR.
>> Bret: WITH LEAKS OR
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> ANY NUMBER OF WAYS, THEY
BECOME GOOD AT THAT.
ON THE SESSIONS QUESTION IN
GENERAL, YOU GO BACK TO HIS
TESTIMONY ON JANUARY 10TH, WHERE
HE SAID THAT HE DID NOT HAVE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH RUSSIANS
WHEN HE WAS ASKED WHO QUESTIONED
BY AL FRANKEN.
SESSIONS MAINTAINS THAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT IN A CAMPAIGN
CONTEXT.
HE'S ADMITTED THAT HE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN MORE FORTHCOMING BY
ALLOWING FOR HIS TWO MEETINGS
WITH SERGEY KISLYAK.
HE ALSO INVOLVE OPERATIVE MATTER
ON JANUARY 17TH SAID HE HAD NOT
HAD COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
ELECTION, RESPONDING TO
SENATOR LEAHY HE.
IF THERE HAD BEEN SUCH AN
INVESTIGATION AND IF WE WERE TO
BELIEVE THE STATEMENT FROM
JEFF SESSIONS' ATTORNEY, HE'S
BEEN FOUND TO HAVE NOT COMMITTED
PERJURY BECAUSE THE
INVESTIGATION IS NOW OVER.
>> Bret: IN THE MEANTIME, ALL
OF THIS TALK ABOUT RUSSIA, THE
TESTIMONY ON CAPITOL HILL, PLUS
"THE WASHINGTON POST" RUNS THE
STORY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT FOLLOW
SPECIFIC WARNINGS FROM HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISORS
TUESDAY WHEN HE CONGRATULATED
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
ON HIS REELECTION, INCLUDING A
SECTION IN HIS BRIEFING
MATERIALS, AND ALL CAPITAL
LETTERS, STATING "DO NOT
CONGRATULATE."
TRUMP ALSO CHOSE NOT TO HEED
TALKING POINTS FROM AIDES
INSTRUCTING HIM TO CONDEMN THE
RECENT POISONING OF A FORMER
RUSSIAN SPY WITH POWERFUL NERVE
AGENTS.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING, "I
CALLED PRESIDENT PUTIN OF RUSSIA
TO CONGRATULATE HIM ON HIS
ELECTION VICTORY.
IN THE PAST OBAMA CALLED HIM
ALSO.
THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA IS CRAZED
BECAUSE THEY WANTED ME TO
EXCORIATE HIM.
THEY ARE WRONG.
GETTING ALONG WITH RUSSIA AND
OTHERS IS A GOOD THING, NOT A
BAD THING.
IT CAN HELP SOLVE PROBLEMS WITH
NORTH KOREA, SYRIA, UKRAINE,
ISIS, RHONDA, AND BECOMING'S
ARMS RACE.
BUSH TRIED TO GET ALONG WITH
THAT AND HAVE THE SMARTS.
OBAMA AND CLINTON TRIED BUT
DIDN'T HAVE THE ENERGY OR
CHEMISTRY.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH."
THAT WAS A BIG RESPONSE BY THE
PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW, WHAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS BILL IS NOT ONLY THE
CALL ITSELF AND THE UPROAR ABOUT
IT, OBVIOUSLY COME ON ALL SIDES.
BUT YOU     THIS WEEK ABOUT THEA
BUT YOU     THIS WEEK ABOUT THET
BUT YOU     THIS WEEK ABOUT THEL
DOCUMENT, THAT WE DON'T KNOW IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP READ OR DIDN'T.
BUT THE FACT THAT IT'S OUT THERE
FOR YOU.
>> IT'S AMAZING.
SOMEBODY WHO HAD TOP-SECRET
BRIEFINGS, GO OVERCOME US
SEPTIMUS GIVEN THE WHITE HOUSE,
THERE HAS TO BE VERY FEW PEOPLE,
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
SITTING AROUND THAT TABLE AND
LOOKING AT THESE DOCUMENTS.
SO THEY HAVE GOT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
I BELIEVE THERE WASN'T AN
INVESTIGATION STARTED SIX MONTHS
AGO, A YEAR AGO, BUT I THINK
SESSIONS ARE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO LOOK INTO LEAKS.
DO I HAVE THIS RIGHT OR WRONG?
I DON'T THINK ANYTHING HAS BEEN
RESOLVED.
CONGRATULATIONS TO PUTIN?
EVERYBODY HAS POINTED OUT THAT
OBAMA DID THIS AND OBAMA ALSO
CONGRATULATE TO THE PRESIDENT OF
IRAN ON HIS.
A LITTLE HISTORY HERE.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT BAD
RUSSIANS, CHURCHILL, I CHECKED
MY BOOKS, CHURCHILL
CONGRATULATED STALIN ON HIS
BIRTHDAY, GOD KNOWS ONE OF THE
WORST DAYS IN HISTORY OF THE
WORLD, THE BIRTHDAY OF JOSEPH
STALIN.
CHURCHILL SAID THAT, THE GREAT
STATESMAN.
I WAS WATCHING ONE OF THE OTHER
CABLE NETWORKS AND THEY WERE
HIGHLY INSULTED BECAUSE THEY
SAID THE PRESIDENT HAS INSULTED
US AND MERYL STREEP AND CHUCK
TODD BUT    .
MAY BE THE PRESIDENT THINGS
PUTIN MIGHT BE USEFUL FOR
INTERNATIONAL NEGOTIATIONS IN
THE WAY CHUCK TODD, MERYL STREEP
MAY NOT BE.
>> Bret: KAREN?
>> THIS IS AT ODDS WITH MEMBERS
OF HIS ADMINISTRATION.
HIS ADMINISTRATION AS HAVING
SANCTIONED RUSSIA OVER THE
ELECTION INTERFERENCE, THEY ARE
TRYING TO PROJECT THAT THEY ARE
GETTING TOUGH ON RUSSIA.
THIS SUGGESTS THE OPPOSITE.
THE FACT THAT THIS NOTE, THIS
PIECE OF ADVICE, DO NOT
CONGRATULATE WAS LEAKED, SUGGEST
A HIGH DEGREE OF FRUSTRATION
WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE OVER THE
FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING
ONE WAY AND THE NATIONAL
SECURITY TEAM WANTS TO GO
ANOTHER WAY.
>> Bret: I WOULD JUST SAY
THIS.
JOHN ROBERTS IS REPORTING THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF LIVID PEOPLE
INSIDE THAT WHITE HOUSE,
INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT, ABOUT
THAT PARTICULAR ELEMENT AT THIS
STORY.
>> IT MAY JUST BE ONE PERSON.
HOW MANY TIMES DID RONALD REAGAN
HOW MANY TIMES DID RONALD REAGA
RONALD REAGAN -- SPEECHWRITERS
AND STAFF CROSS DOWN "TEAR DOWN
THIS WALL."
TURNS OUT I WAS A GOOD IDEA.
>> THE LEAK IS EXTRAORDINARY.
THE BIG STORY IS RUSSIA.
RUSSIA IS ACTING LIKE AN ENEMY,
DONALD TRUMP IS TREATING THEM
LIKE A FRIEND.
HE WANTS RUSSIA TO SOLVE OUR
PROBLEMS WITH HER UKRAINE?
HE IS CAUSING PROBLEMS OF
UKRAINE.
RUSSIA IS BLOCKING FOR IRAN AT
THE U.N. SECURITY COUNCIL.